if the Israeli Army decides to go ahead
with a ground offensive that's meant to
remove Hamas from Power that's the sort
of thing that could draw in other groups
around the region and then this becomes
a much bigger Regional war and and all
bets are off at that point I also think
that at some point whether or not the
Israelis think that there was direct
Iranian involvement in in organizing
this attack I think at some point they
will want to settle accounts with the
Iranians but I don't think they're going
to want to do that soon uh because they
have a concern about this becoming a
multi-front war I mean they're having
still a difficult time regaining control
of their own territory and securing
their own territory the last thing they
want is for this to turn into a
multi-front war so whatever response it
is they might direct at Iran I think
that's something they're going to try
and push off into the longer term